I've never seen these kind of readings
from very suit straddling over 2.86
billion joules of energy that's a
combined equivalent of almost three
lighting bills
hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 11 video there was a
whole bunch of Easter eggs we even got
to watch Barry Hulk out on speed force
so we got to break it down there's a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
episode on the video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet here
we go top 10 WTF and Easter eggs so
starting with cicadas list there was a
giant list of names
most of these were people from the
production in comic book names anytime
there's a giant list they always put a
lot of comic book Easter eggs on it but
they also just because there are so many
names they can't always use a bunch of
comic book characters so they'll put
people from real life on the list or
just random people that the writers and
the producers like in real life so Kira
Mae is a musician in real life Geist is
a Batman villain from the Chuck Dixon
run Bork is an actual Batman villain
like he was their Hodor at the beginning
of the episode he held the door for noir
Vox so they could get away I couldn't
find Ke$ha more anywhere she's probably
somebody from the production in real
life
Zack Mueller is a politician they list
him for petty theft so maybe that's them
making a political joke Shawna Baez is
peekaboo she was a big part of the
episode he Saunders is a Broadway star
in real life Reed rice Alice Astaire
knows Daniel Calvert Ian Shire and Greg
Anderson are all different people from
the production nor vaak obviously a big
part of the episode and then I couldn't
read that last name but number 9 Bork
holds the door so that Norwalk can get
away now obviously this is all setting
up the idea that villains can also do
good things so you should treat them
just like you treat normal people it's
been a big arc on the flash this season
especially with Nora in weather which I
don't know if that's meant to be
political allegory for real life like
reaching across the aisle being nice to
the people on the other side or anything
like that but they have been getting
pretty political with the DC TV shows
this year the whole thing with Bork is
that his special power in the comics is
immunity to magic but he's also like a
really big person this is kind of what
he looks like though so the flash
version is just a little bit different
they sort of set up the running plotline
with a cure in the background Caitlin
needs
DNA from one of these new metahumans
which she then gets by the end of the
episode because of her killer frost arc
which I'll talk about that second
because they had this whole big thing
going on between the two of them but you
get a little bit more Abair and Nora
doing the CSI thing they've been trying
to do more and more that this season
because that is Barry's real job when
he's not being the flash number eight
Sherlock versus Nora I actually kind of
like this storyline I haven't been so
happy with Sherlock in the first couple
of episodes of the season but I feel
like he's got a lot more interesting now
that he's pursuing Nora in trying to out
this big mystery of who she's working
with in the future
he starts studying her journal and
starts wondering about the timeline
really the big payoff of his arc in this
episode was learning that there
definitely was two different people that
were working on this special journal of
speed force symbols in the time language
that she had like uh there is another
person that's helping her in the future
and I love the way that as they shot
that his face was transposed on the
journal because his face is the same
face as the reverse-flash who is the
person that's helping her in the future
number seven cicada destroys Nora's
spine so you get to see him eviscerate
another metahuman that was on that list
like it's getting pretty gruesome like
he's getting more and more powerful so
he's just ripping through them in broad
daylight he just does not care at all
but very clearly this is meant to be a
mirror of zoom breaking Barry spine guys
I can't feel my legs the only thing
about this storyline that I wasn't quite
as happy with was how thick they laid it
on like they really want you to worry
about Nora but they bent over backwards
to let you know that she was healing and
she would get better I don't you know
people maybe they forgot about what
happened during season two like oh yeah
their speedsters they'll heal super fast
the whole way they explained her not
healing faster was because Sakata took
her powers away with the Speed Force
dagger before he broke her back but I
guess the way they're explaining the
powers of the dagger on the TV show is
that as long as they're not in proximity
to it the effects of the dagger will
slowly wear off meaning that their
powers will return I was a little upset
that they didn't wheel out Harrison
wells chair I felt like that would have
been an awesome reference to make like
oh we have a wheelchair that you can
wheel around in for a second and it
would've just been another way to tie
her to the reverse-flash in the future
because that's the same chair that he
was wheeling around in in the hundredth
episode when they went back to visit him
and throughout season one six was killer
frost versus Caitlyn because of the cure
does I mean they had a couple of funny
moments between the two of them with
killer frost like erasing and rewriting
and just trolling her on her dry erase
board then later in the episode she just
flat-out breaks it and Caitlyn's I God
Jesus what am I gonna do now this was
one of the other storylines where the
writers tried to bend over backwards to
let you know that Caitlyn never wanted
to take the Cure like she tries to tell
killer frost no matter what happens I
don't want to take this at least at the
beginning killer frost is like yeah I'll
believe it when I see like she's not so
ready to trust Caitlyn implicitly but
then by the end of the episode they sort
of come to an agreement and even though
killer frost is right to be wary of this
like it's definitely gonna fall into the
hands of someone bad and go completely
off the rails but it's the writers
letting you know that killer frost is
always gonna be killer frost like we did
that in previous seasons with Caitlyn's
character where she had her powers then
she lost her powers then season 5 is all
about finding the balance between the
two of them and becoming a more fully
actualized version of the character
number 5 was that second conversation
that Sherlock had with Nora maybe you
could just take me to that flash Museum
in the future is it safe for non
speedsters to travel through the Speed
Force with you that's all very clearly
set up for Barry and iris to go to the
flash Museum in next week's episode
albeit through Nora's mind like they
don't physically travel to the flash
Museum as far as we know just based on
the teaser they're traveling through
Nora's memories of the flash Museum and
that sort of explains how you get this
weird walking version of the reverse
flash suit with no face in it like what
the hell is going on here well now we
know it's just a memory so it's sort of
this nightmare that she's experiencing
number 4 was flash for cicada brawl in
the pool hall that is just a
knock-down-drag-out by Barry smashes the
chair across it was the beginning of
their WWE part of the episode now he
gets his ass handed to him until he gets
killer Frost's help later during their
second fight during the episode
so number three killer frost
flash tag team against cicada the way
they explain killer frost immunity to
cicada is that his dagger can only leech
the dark matter from metahumans that
were created in a very specific way
people like berry people like the recent
metahumans the reason why killer frost
is immune to that is because she got her
powers biologically through a completely
different way she can still be dazed
like when he uses that big area of
effect attack but she can use her powers
to keep the dagger at bay and then berry
number two just completely hooks out on
speed force
gonna hurt my daughter again
[Music]
so now this isn't him using negative
speed force or anything like that but
they're slowly
I think pushing into that idea and it
depends on how the TV show wants to use
that as a concept narrative Li but in
the comics there's a very specific way
that the negative speed force works it
sort of pollutes the flash and makes him
kind of evil or at least give in to his
more baser instincts and sort of
explains why the reverse-flash is the
way that he is because the negative
speed force makes you give in to all the
worst things in your personality he gets
way more aggressive way more destructive
so maybe they'll deal with that in a
future season on the TV show don't worry
too much about it right now but this is
all about compassion like remember that
overarching storyline treat the villains
like you would treat normal people so
Nora gets buried to chill out like
please don't kill him because that will
only make things worse number one WTF
was cicada looking at that evil
scrapbook at the end of the episode with
Cisco and Nora pictures in it just
letting you know that he would be
targeting them in an upcoming episode
also probably trying to steal that cure
from Cisco but obviously there's a big
twist where Barry's like I get it we can
defeat cicada by healing his knees so
will appeal to his heart they also
really tried to lay it on thick how much
Barry cares about Nora that's clearly
meant to set up the big reversal when he
finds out that she's been lying to them
this whole time and working with reverse
flash so that the truth of that lands on
him so much harder like oh I care about
her so much how could she betray me oh
my god like you know big WTF moment so
let me know if there are any Easter eggs
that you spotted in the episode that I
didn't include in the video I'll be
working on my trailer video for next
week's episode and some new Game of
Thrones next that should post in the
next couple of hours we just learned a
whole bunch of really cool stuff on a my
giveaway winner when I post that flash
trailer video click here for my brand
new Avengers endgame teaser breakdown
and click here for my brand new Shazam
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
guys tonight
[Music]